hello
i'm going to talk tonight about audio
psychoacoustics and speech quality
measurements
and actually we're going to focus on the
missing matrix and how to train models
without it
my name is
orianne
and i work at app ai it's a consultancy
and projects company
i founded two years ago with a partner
that happens to sit here by such a
random chance
and
i'm coming from neuroscience i have an
ma
in a computational branch of cognition
which means i love perception and
psychoacoustics and i love
computational human human related models
writing them thinking about them
and i also happen to have background in
radio i worked for the radio for a
couple of years and music
and it's not related to this talk but i
happen to love language as well
so let's talk about what we're talking
about tonight
we will talk about the purpose of this
talk and then go over
the human audio perception and what we
know about it
and
then we'll go over the world's shortest
history of the field
talk about general approaches for
measuring perceptual audio quality
and have a short conclusion and that
will be it
[Music]
so
the purpose of this talk
start or maybe how this talk started
was
when i had encountered a challenge in
work
we work a lot in the domain of audio
and i wrote in the israeli group speech
recognition israel a question which i
thought that would be super easy i
thought it's going to be like two hours
i was like i'm looking for an algorithm
that compares audio a to audio b and
grades how similar or different are the
two tracks
and what i didn't know that this would
cause a very long debate between
everyone that is in the group
and also that
even though i thought that measuring
quality is a very hard task and i
thought that there might be an easy way
to compare if something is similar or
auditory
experienced different between two tracks
this actually is also a very hard task
and there is no one solution to it
and it's not only a hard task that
there's no solution to
it's also
many different questions
when i wrote this in the facebook group
what
all the
wonderful supportive
colleagues uh that responded said was
that this is
like what is your task
this is so these are so many different
tasks and every task is approached
differently in a different algorithm
i'm going to try and generalize this and
to approach this as one task but in
order to do this let me try and
phrase the question uh in a way that
will
catch all the different questions that
there are inside of it and in order to
do so please
if you
see that there's
a task or some sort of uh
challenge that i didn't approach in this
um
phrasing tell me later
so
the one the one way to phrase it all
is
how to measure the quality
and or intelligibility
of artificially generated and or edited
speech and or music live and or offline
with and or without reference in lossy
and or regular conditions for
professional and or day-to-day use cases
these are all the problems
um
and and and indeed if you look at the
field
each and every one of
combination that derives out of this
sentence is a field within itself
and there is a long history of of of
conventions of what people do in that
field
and so but still the starting point is
rather similar the starting point is
understanding how the human audio
perception works or at least to try and
understand it because in the end
everything that we do reaches our ears
and if we'd understand something about
how our ears and brain
perceptual experience of sound sounds or
works we'll be able to do it better
okay
so
the
starting point of this track is that our
this uh
i don't know
journey is that human hearing is not the
same as the audio signal what we hear
our experience of sound is not the same
as the actual vibration of sound in the
air
that creates that experience
and
it's different in a way that is very
hard to catch
but we can still talk about it
first of all when we talk about audio or
speech or sound what are we talking
about
many people like to
stare and hypnotize themselves looking
at this gift
which resembles or trying to which which
demonstrates how um
sound travels through the air and
reaches our ears
um i think it's it's too hypnotizing so
i will say that i think about it as
ripples in water
that are all around us it's like
three-dimensional
it travels over time
it reaches our ears and it has two
things that are worth mentioning which
is loudness
and also frequency
the way to look at it in a graph
is uh
like
like that as you see here i think it's
too small isn't it real
it's great
yeah of course you're my uh perceptual
test for for seeing this lecture
um so what we see here
on the x-axis is the different
frequencies on the y-axis is the
physical metric of the sound pressure
level or decibels
and on these wavy lines
it's
phones which is the metrics used to
describe how humans
feel or experience the loudness of sound
and what we see in this graph
is that
within the
human voice range which is approximately
between 120
and
5 000
we have the best and
best resolution and best ability to tell
the difference between
loudness and uh different frequencies
and it's kind of like a chicken and an
egg situation but like we are
specialists
in hearing the
range of voice
and maybe you know voice was
adjusted to the way we hear or maybe our
hearing was adjusted to the way we speak
i don't know
but still
the other thing that is interesting in
this graph is that
it's definitely not linear i mean
this wavy
formula
um is is is not behaving as you know one
um straight line
but still it's it's possible to yeah
to describe it
um okay
so this is a word about our perception
and what's not in the graph and not in
this talk at all is situations where our
brain even
can give us the experience of listening
to something that doesn't exist at all
or
uh subtract something out of our of out
of like existing signal in a way that we
want we will not notice
so this
entire thing is happening and now we
need to find a way to create an
algorithm that tell us if something is
the same or is different between two
tracks
[Music]
so the world's shortest history of the
field is that it started off
around the beginning of the 20th century
when telecommunication and radio began
because this is when we actually
had machines that allow us to use audio
in many different possibilities and we
had to learn how to build them the right
way that would reach our ears in the
best possible situation
afterwards
um
[Music]
like
skip many many years ahead we reached
the 80s and 90s
where telecommunication
companies ruled this world and created
many different algorithms
to tell the quality of sound but they
they were patented and
costed money you had to buy
a license to use them and it was very
expensive it's still very expensive to
this day to use these algorithms
and in the recent past like 10 to 20
years
the big companies uh that rule
you know the computer science industry
are getting more and more into this
uh field as well
and you can see today we're going to
talk a bit about a google algorithm and
to mention a facebook algorithm
and
they are not only
that they're new and are trying to
address situations of neural network
based algorithms but also
they are open sourced which is a very
big change in the mindset of how these
things work
so everything we're gonna talk about
will refer to this uh specific
test which is called moss there is a
similar test that sometimes is used
which is called mushra
it is the mean opinion score
and it is how sound was measured and
tested for
many many years and still is the most
common way to test the sound the quality
of sound
the way this test works is
that you
do the manipulation you want to do
about for for the track you're editing
or actually for
a big set of tracks you are trying to
test
and then you give many different
listeners
to listen to the different tracks and
grade them as a whole
between one which are which is a very
very bad score and five which is an
excellent score the quality or
intelligibility it really depends
is uh really good
this is a hard task like perceptually
think about this if you if you need to
sit and listen to degraded sounds that
have bad quality to to say
for each and every track how bad it is
and scale it between one and five is not
such an easy thing to do
and so
it's a task that humans don't do so well
and you can see this if you compare
different
tests for different situations
and there is a researcher called erica
cooper who did who did that recently
and what she saw was that
within each task
this scale is great but if you try to
generalize the
test and look between different tasks
you can't really say anything like if a
mos test
is good for one situation and and
gave you the the average of four and for
a different situation also gave you the
average of four if you compare these two
fours
it's not necessarily means that they
would like people in a in a test that
would contain everything would say about
these two tracks that they are for
so
that's quite a hard task and still like
this is the industry industry standard
this is what everyone uses
and everything that happened after this
is trying to create the most
scale which means that
even algorithms
for from
recent years from these years that are
trying to create a comparison
will eventually compare them to the mean
opinion score
they're just like what google does what
facebook does is essentially
giving the score between one and five
and compare their algorithms to most
tests that they perform
on the task that they're testing
yes
okay so you're asking if the quality of
sound is related to shazam
shazam like algorithms fingerprinting
yeah the shazam algorithm is amazing
it's a great paper
but i don't like it doesn't have
anything to do
like directly with what we're talking
about here except for maybe
i i don't know it sounds like i think
like it's it's the general domain but
there isn't anything specifically that
that we're trying to do that is similar
here
yes
because each person is different in
is this a bug or a feature though i mean
if you're trying to make something you
want it to apply for everyone's hearing
i mean you can imagine a world and i
would definitely love to imagine that
world that everyone's specific way and
range of hearing will be adjusted to by
the different
things like mecha like machines we use
and then if someone has degraded hearing
then their hearing would be exactly
you know fitted like that the output of
of their phone would be fitted to their
their hearing um
but i mean is this what you're asking
not exactly but when you're
trying to get a different person and
the same track and try to find and
[Music]
so definitely and what the way that this
test is is performed is to give the
rating
for many different people
and also even if you do that some some
statisticians will tell you that this
test is is not statistically correct
because what you do after many people
different people rate it you take the
the mean of it the arithmetic mean as
your final score for that track but this
is an ordinal scale you can't really say
that something that is good and got the
um
the grade of four is two times better
perceptually than something that got the
grade two
and so some people would say that in
this case the best thing to take is um
the median like when you study
statistics in school that that's what
they teach you and still this is the
industry standard and they take the
arithmetic mean and they have taken it
for years so this is what everyone does
and so also in psychology and
neuroscience right this is from
psychology psychology and neuroscience i
mean like looking at psychophysics and
perception it's a field that was
established by physicists that turn that
this understood that their perception is
standing in the way of understanding the
world so maybe they should look at their
perception when they look at the world
and one more question is you said about
intelligibility
how do you define this in this conflict
so from what they see what difference
the difference is uh not in definition
it's in what you ask the people that
that answer the most test if you tell
them please tell us which
which uh of how intelligible is the
track that's one question and if you ask
them please tell us what is the best
best sounding track or piece of music i
don't know then it's a different
question and a different essentially a
different task
what do you mean by intelligibility i
mean um so you can understand this in
some way but i'm just wondering like
what is the underlying idea behind this
question
um
yeah of course
that um algorithms from the 90s that
worked on phones try to uh measure the
the
width the bandwidth that is possible
like kind of like testing the
information system like how how how can
you
degrade
and also compress the sound enough but
still keep it
understandable to the person who's
listening to it so do use because like
for for i think for voice it's kind of
intuitive but do we also use it for
music for instance for music no from
music the question is different
intelligibility refers to
speech
yeah
thank you yeah sure
maybe if i can
offer
and you gave the
whole group both traps the truck that
you want to test and distracted everyone
created the score okay you
you give them the test okay and they
read it they so you're suggesting to
train them
show them not exactly like trying to
understand
how much their bias
as opposed to the whole population
because
yeah
the chance that the population that you
and youtube is like the entire
population is really low so this is this
is yeah this is your your idea is great
it's in use in in
all sorts of ways
um it's this is a reduced like talk
about how do we measure the mean opinion
score because it's a small lecture but i
i can talk to you later and tell you all
the lengthy explanations and of how this
is verified and double triple quadruple
checked
but definitely this happens because
you're right you're absolutely right
people are different from each other and
you're trying to calibrate everyone for
to to what is excellent good fair poor
and bad
let's go
okay so now we're gonna talk about like
the general approach for measuring
perceptual audio we will start together
in a very naive way
of comparing two tracks and then we'll
go right into the point where everyone
agrees upon and will stop and talk about
what
is added in the
newer and recent recent algorithms and
that would be it so let's go
okay so the very general naive approach
is starting with two tracks and asking
how can i compare these two tracks and
say if they're the same or different
maybe i will just i should just take the
waveform of these two tracks
and subtract them from one another
and if they're exactly the same then the
result will be zero which is this is the
case here the blue and the red
waves here are exactly identical
and if i subtract them from one another
i get this
just you know no signal
and just for
the sports we will listen to them
so they they're both the same they're
from library speech which is
a data set for training text to speech
which is
comprised of many people reading books
so it's just one
small example from that
we were so deep in the grass that we
could see nothing but the blue sky over
us
and the gold tree in front of us
so
what we see here is that actually this
may be a good direction we just need to
subtract one track from the other and
that's it
but
if we do a minor change for the track
and add
a bit of silence in the beginning of the
reference the first one and a bit of
silence in the in the ending of the
degraded one
we would expect or
we and listen to the result
what we hear our experience of that of
the subtraction of the orange part
is that it's not that different
let's listen to that
we were so deep into the graphs that we
could see nothing with the blue sky over
us and a gold tree in front of us
so it's not exactly the same but it's
rather similar it's still very
understandable
and if our measurement would have been
the subtractions of the two or the
correlation of the two we would have
gotten a very poor result
and
the reason this is this is happening
is that the sample rate of
of the wav file is
i think it's 44
yeah 44 100
um samples per second
and just shifting five taking
distorting it so
slightly is not something that our human
hears
can really
you know
experience
and so what most people do at this stage
is that they shift from the wave form to
the
logarithmic spectrogram
form
and
the way that this is done
is that a window
is scanning the waveform and every 80 to
or 80 or 100
milliseconds is one column in that
in this graph
and a fourier transform tells us in
every
column that is 80 to 100 milliseconds
which of the frequencies is loudest and
this is what we see here i knew it would
be hard to see
in in purple
and still what what is important to to
see here
is that
oppa
is that still
like most of the spectrogram is not in
use because the high higher scales of
frequencies are just not something that
there is signal at
um
and
already by doing this if we subtract
this from that
we see that uh it's almost like it's
completely black which means that
it's almost completely silent
and
the one more thing i did not mention
about like how to look at spectral
grounds is that the y-axis is the
frequencies
and the color scale
is
the loudness or the decibels
so
the lighter areas
mean that these are the loudest areas of
the track
so the one step forward after this
would be to ask
is this good enough or should we maybe
do a log mel spectrogram which
scales the frequencies to
the range at which we are most
uh that we hear the most at and so now
we're using all of the picture
and it's we're getting one step closer
to the way that the human ear perceives
sounds
and still here the subtraction works
great
still with this uh small addition in the
beginning and the end
and now the question is what is the next
step
because this looks quite well
but still we see that if we compare two
tracks to to one another like this we
can still add noise to one track
and
um
the wheel there we can create a
situation where there is a slight small
noise
all across uh the track
and
it will
show in the subtraction of the two
tracks
but to our ears it will not be audible
so we look at
an example like that
so we still need a
yeah we still need to turn the light
sorry
[Laughter]
thank you mother hi
so here we added like stochastic noise
to our uh degraded track which is always
called degraded even when it's better
it's like the bias terms of the field
and the subtraction shows us that there
is noise in here but this this noise is
inaudible and i will demonstrate that
we were so deep in the grass that we
could see nothing but the blue sky over
us
and a gold tree in front of us
you want to hear the the reference
original or we
should we go forward
you believe me
this is the the reference
we were so deep in the grass that we
could see nothing but the blue sky over
us
this is the noisy the noisy example
we were so deep in the grass that we
could see nothing but the blue sky over
us and a gold tree in front of us
so still there are problems here
it's not good enough
and
this is what everyone agrees upon like
what we went through this this far is
pretty much the industry standard is
what you do to almost every task you
need to to use
and
um
this is the list of like
licensed and open source
telecommunication algorithms and their
war against open source
big companies algorithms
and i want to touch briefly upon what is
uh what is it in the new algorithms that
make them slightly better so this is the
fiscal score the google algorithm score
for this that the noisy track that we
just heard
and it has several different additions
to everything discussed so far first of
all
it's created to compare intelligibility
and
the timeline alignment is cut to one
second patches
that are then
being correlated between the reference
and degraded part
and this is closer to the human
forgiveness towards delays some delays
we just don't notice
and this takes that into account
also
once the correlation is achieved between
the two parts
time where time warping is being um
tried which means that like
there is a stretching and shrinking
of uh the
reference
and
to an extent because the human ear
is also allowing
like slightly stretched or
shrunk versions of audio without really
noticing so this is also happening
the last thing is that
the two last things is that
voice activity detection vad
is uh
being calculated all over the two tracks
because in very silent tracks it does
not make sense to compare silences
because when you compare silences the
different structure of silence can be
different
and it can
look like there's a big difference
between two tracks when actually there
isn't
and also um structural in the end
structural singularity is being computed
on the two tracks
um which is called like antsy
and if you
if you've ever taken uh image processing
course it's it's similar to s sim
um and it's basically
look finding the way to adjust the
tracks
so that
we will look at the forest and not the
trees we will compare like the big
picture of uh the two tracks not the
specifics of each and every
sample
okay so conclusions
if you are or if i'm starting a new
audio project how should i approach
establishing matrices
metrics for it
um
sadly there is no one true way to do it
nothing is set in
set in stone and establishing the metric
you will use is a task within itself
the first step would be to find relevant
review papers to have a benchmark
after wait afterwards i would suggest
curating an audio test library that
covers your major use cases
then if possible add a tiny internal mos
test to the team members and you which
is a way to get everyone involved and
also understand like the sort of task
you're dealing with which is something
no one ever talks about in
machine learning but it's really
important because when you listen to the
samples yourself and also have the
product manager of the team listen to
them you get a so much better idea of
what is the type of
task you're trying to achieve
and then
once happy with results insist of
running a large mos test because this is
still the industry standard and the only
thing you can really rely upon
if you want to to test many different
situations
and after obtaining the most tests uh
you should calibrate it to the existing
algorithms and don't be afraid to try
and mix and match and try different
variations of those algorithms because
as i said
nothing is set in stone and there is no
one answer to this question
thank you that's it
so i'm wondering like what is the main
um
let's say use case or business need
behind all this that we
talked about today so i imagine that
you might want to
compare two waveforms and
say how similar they are to each other
you might
also want to compare them and say
well one is intelligible while the other
maybe not enough right so
first of all in
speech
generation in audio generation think
about all those series and alexas
talking to you
you want to try and find the best and
most natural way to create
these algorithms but it's that's not the
only use case but let's talk about this
for example so let's say you're an
engineer working on such a problem and
you have a version of the algorithm
let's call it version 64. you've already
worked a lot and you think you did
something right and you have a good
version it's already working and you
want to know if you want and and you
have an idea it's a bit exploratory but
it has good potential
and you're trying to branch it and
create it
like version 65
and you want to tell you you want to try
and convince your boss that version 65
is the one that should be implemented in
all of the devices how how do you go
about this most times when you're like
working on an engineering task it's not
that an improvement
is something as robust that you can say
look at it it's a knockout most times it
would be slightly better and many times
slightly not so good and even degrading
in different areas and you want to
establish some sort of metric to talk
about
that you can just say look
it improved our whatever it is we're
measuring we should move to version 65.
like in the developing process this is
something i encounter every day i
encounter like
it's re i think all of us do it in
different ways especially like in nlp
and also in recommender systems how do
you know that whatever it is you're
working on is now better than what it
was in the previous version of it
like let's assume you did not do like a
better version that knocked it all out
or you know
caused the company to to close and blame
the
engineers in it that that the models
weren't good enough for predicting house
values in the states or something
very kind
yeah so that would be um
for a voice generating system
voice generating system voice editing
system any anything that is voice
related really anything that that
yeah that's that's the the main idea and
the main domain so this is just one
domain which happens to be extremely
percep
perceptual
but this is like a truth of the truth of
the industry in a way
okay
yes dear uh
thank you for waiting till the end
the comparison should be local
they
so it's kind of like global to local
trade-off right if you look at it super
local then it's hard if you look at it
really glo like it's it's the question
of of of where is the like right spot
yeah but you used global method for the
end especially did you try to use
wavelet and
method that support the locality so
parts of the things i showed later what
they do is they chop up
the track to many different areas and
also
they
yeah yeah and they they look at the
local
comparison
more and they do some kind of a hybrid
mesh i mean i skipped i skipped the
actual part that goes because this we
don't have a lot of time and it's late
but like yeah there's like
there's a whole world out there and i
can send you papers
if you want stephan
[Music]
okay
thank you all for surviving
9 00 pm with me so let's talk about it
here come on let's
[Applause]